e
e e
supposed to have this on right yep
um the point to this this whole bill
that's been going on now my
understanding since
2017 is that um we know that there's a
problem with pain care in the United
States that we have a prescription and a
procedure epidemic um but we don't
really provide access to services that
we think help meaning like integrative
care which is putting all these things
together in a unified piece which we
know works for chronic disabilities that
model works the best um but we also know
that we tell people you can't have pills
but we think you should be able to do
this this and that and the patient will
commonly say well I can't access that
for a variety of reasons not the least
of which is cost so the whole point of
this bill from the very beginning was to
provide an alternative to opioid therapy
the people have been asking for for a
long time um I think we've made some
progress but we have a long ways to go
and that was the point so the next thing
that we've been doing this has been an
ongoing discussion that some of us in
this room have been involved with for at
least six years um and it's actually
what led to me running for this office
which is why I'm sitting here right now
and maybe we'll be sitting here again in
January hopefully
um I I did cheuck with my mental health
expert and they said it was fine um but
anyways um
anybody yeah a lot of people right four
Dems and six Republicans all together
they can't be all they must
be four seats for four seats yeah so um
yeah it's it's going to be a
challenge how many
Democrats there's four Dems in our
running in our
our um District I think pretty much sure
four so they they they won't have a
primary they they did that on purpose I
I actually work with them on a regular
basis on a lot of stuff so I know the
inside dirt but the Republicans there
were two new ones that chose to
run um we'll see I'm not as confident as
you are but anyway so that that's kind
of where we are with this bill I I um I
think the bill needs a lot of work um I
tried to put together something that
I've shared with all of you um and I
would be happy to start anywhere um
representative Palmer and I talked in
the cafeteria earlier and I don't know
how much you want me to go over the
history of this before we get into
that all right so um actually I
met um M croll and Miss Don like as part
of this process about Gary Merchant
several year representative Gary
Merchant uh several years ago um put
together an ad hoc committee to look at
how we provide nonopioid Therapies in
the state and um I don't think there was
a clear Direction Where We wanted that
to go but I was actually kind of not
totally invited to that um um I was
actually supposed to go to a different
committee but Jim Potter asked me to
attend on behalf of the med Society so I
went and when I sat down when I realized
that not a single person in the room
knew what the CDC guidelines to opio
prescribing was I knew that there was a
problem so I immediately gave a
discussion on that and um the next thing
I know is Gary Merchant says you
shouldn't be out there you should be up
here so the next thing I know when you
were there too and I I I got asked to go
sit up there and Peter Schmidt came
later and whatever um but anyways um it
was a really great process um that
committee led to three bills um one of
which passed which is one that I wrote
with um uh ironically Bill Murphy on no
relation um but it changed the way we we
allow prescribing opioids in the state
which helped patients which is a good
thing um but anyways in the midst of all
that um representative maputi was there
at several meetings and she was talking
about a bill that she wanted to create
um she's that basically is what the
first two sections of this bill are or
three sections I think um the ones that
are all bleed
out so um you know it was the problem
with the bill was it made sense it
wanted to increase access to these
services but it put in a lot of
restrictions on doctors who prescribe
and so that raised a lot of warning
signs for us because to be honest
everything that was in that section was
already in our rules so um we met
together as a separate ad hoc group um
San Savage me Jim Potter Mike padmore
and Cindy Steinberg U the reason why
Cindy is important is she is a
legislative director for the US pain
foundation and the Executive Vice
President for the Massachusetts pain
initiative she's been involved in
National pain policy for over 20 years
and there was a similar Bill crafted in
Massachusetts that she was the author of
so she and I've been friends for a long
time and I asked her up and get involved
and advise us so a lot of what you're
seeing in the second section the part
that's not bed out in this is the work
that we all did together um we all
agreed something needed a change um how
purpose of that was that existing law um
not
really wonder why I've never seen that
before seen a different color oh oh
that's me that's you that's me so
anything that's blue is an edit from the
original Bill okay yeah because I've
never seen that before oh yeah I
normally it's red but my printer
wouldn't do red for some reason when it
came email you got it in red my printer
it in blue don't I have no idea why my
printer yeah so um so basically anything
in blue that's struck out is something
that's been taken out of the bill that
was in the original bill um anything
that's in blue that's not struck out as
an
addition um so anyway so that's kind of
how we came down to this um you know the
way they did it in Massachusetts was I
mean there was a lot of discussion um
between insurers between
providers um and they came to some
conclusions that that basically mandated
insurers had to provide a plan on how
they provide um integrative services for
pain care that they had to provide so
many visits for I think it was like one
particular modality that they could
choose um and they they gave a basically
the same things that are in this bill
the same options you know whether it was
movement therapies manual therapies
what's important to realize is we're not
talking about physical therapy we're not
talking about occupational therapy we're
not talking about anything that's
already covered um well um so anything
that's not covered well that's provide
and this was the other thing that became
very important our discussions because
the original bill includes ta Chi Yoga
chiong things like that the reason why
those were struck is those are not
provided by licensed providers so we
came to the conclusion based on a
discussion with insurers as well that
the only thing that made any sense from
a legislative point of view was that it
had to be provided by a licensed
provider of some
sort yes and to be honest those those
words we can put back in here I I
struggle with those words but um they
they actually were in here and taken out
um um I struggle with those words
because right now if you look at the
agency for healthc care research quality
report on back pain there's virtually
nothing that
supports anything for back pain so
that's when evidence gets kind of
sketchy with the exception of um two
things um lumbar epidural corro
injection for short-term relief for um
radicular pain and back surgery for
ridic back pain those are the only
things that have any evidence that that
meet met their level with that said
there's an acupuncture project that
lists 117 different diagnoses for which
there's some element of evidence there's
plenty of evidence for cognitive
behavioral therapy for treatment of pain
um there is evidence for massage there
is definitely one of the things that was
presented to our integrative Pain Care
committee from Amy Goldstein from the
alliance to advance comprehensive
integrative pain management was there's
actually strong evidence that um
Chiropractic is cost effective for acute
back
pain um there's the most cost effective
intervention for acute back pain um so
um so yes that we probably should throw
evidence base back in there in
somewhere um but to me I think we kind
of Def need to Define it because I think
we use that term a lot without ever
defining it
yeah I'm pretty much done I think with
the history so um yeah let's let's just
have people talk and we have three
guests in the audience um that are
welcome to speak if they
wishm
bever is that the underl yeah with the
other with that said we do need to
Define What alternative therapies means
if we're going to put that word in
there so is this is this driven by
insurance is it driven by reimbursement
okay it's driven by a lot of separate
stakeholders so I've met I mean as part
of what I do I meet with people all over
the country in different disciplines so
I've met with massage people Psych
people like people um chiropractors I
met with actually both of the State
Chiropractic agencies I actually work
with the acupuncture Association so
we've met with all of them they they're
the ones that are driving this when I
gave you the history what I was trying
to do was give
people's um position on this as best as
I could because it's not that
simple so I'm glad you said that
okay so one of my concerns in practice
always the way
obious can I help you with that so we we
have a an an in house bill 66 now 1712
created a committee that look at Pilot
programs and I do want to stress that I
think what we're doing here is different
than that I'd be happy to address that
if anybody wants me to but our first
session we spent the entire session
coming up with a d def um definition the
pain the definition that's actually in
this here if you look down at the lower
sections pain is defined there but it's
using the International Association for
the study of pain definition the only
minor problem with that and I think we
should modify that to use the same
definition that we used in the
integrative Pain Care committee um but
it it the definition actually appears
twice in the bill um I can find it for
you but I really do think we should use
the definition that we came up with that
representative McKay was a huge help in
helping us with because he said exactly
what you just
said yeah it's the definition if you
look at our report that I actually do
have here um if you look at our report
um we defined it there it's not actually
in the
bill and so at this point it does not
appear in
statute so we can do that
yeah
yep yeah the those definitions actually
came from Cindy Steinberg so that's what
they use in Massachusetts um and that's
what they use nationally but I I based
on our discussions I mean this went on
for two
hours um you know we came I'm sorry I
have the this is the actual report I'll
I'll send you a copy of the actual
definition that we have that we used but
it's it's the International Association
of the study of pain met again um within
the last couple years is redefine pain
um and um it's it's broader it's more
biopsychosocial um um but it it was
really more gerine to what we wanted to
do with that committee and what this
bill and that committee do does overlaps
a lot in that
regard so that
help so
what are options
Avail the
entirely again
y so my this is what I'd like to do I
wanted to start a discussion I wanted we
don't even need to go over in detail
what I did here if you don't want um
which is fine and we can look at it what
I would like to do is put together if
that's all right with you guys um
because this worked really well for our
prior authorization process and also a
couple other things we've done is put
together a small group of people that
represent multiple stakeholders not just
one um and sit down look at this and
come up with something that um I be
honest I really do think we need to move
with this I I don't want to kill this um
but I want to do something that I think
will be
satisfactory from a lot of different
perspectives and what I wrote here to me
is a starting point um and I I I was
under the impression that we needed to
have this done in the next week I found
out we don't so we have the whole summer
to work on it but I mean if if that's if
that's okay with people here that's what
I would like to do um and then have
everybody sit down look at it see what
they think um I will tell you that the
stakeholders that I've referred to
there's not a unanimous belief on this
bill at all all like I I'm on the
legislative committee for the American
of medical acupuncture and I asked him I
says why the hell would you want to do
this and I said you know right now it's
all cash and a lot of the old school
Chiropractic is Cash massage is Cash
which means you don't have an electronic
record you don't need one you certainly
don't have to have an expensive one that
TI and with other systems um you don't
have to get prior authorizations you
don't have any of those headaches and
you can charge a reasonable price and do
what you like to do without any
stress and um about half of them will
say that's what I want the other half
says they want insurance coverage
because it gives them access to
populations they don't have access to
now meaning lower income people things
like that the other little Minor Detail
or problem that you guys have pointed
out multiple times what we're doing here
only affects 22% of the insurance market
and that's a problem and um um um you
know especially when you're looking at
lower income people that group of people
you're looking really more at Medicaid
Medicare um you know especially people
with disabilities they're going to have
potentially both insurances or maybe
more likely Medicare than
Medicaid but we don't have any effect on
that we don't have this bill does not
address the self-insured market either
that's like 78% of the market and that's
a problem and I totally understand why
the ERS have a problem with that is
because you know you're you're basically
limiting it to one small group and and
that's why they have an issue I'm
speaking for you guys sorry but that is
you feel free to say something if you
wish
oh all right can
you you can hear me all right right yeah
okay
I I had no idea we're online oh God I
should have left my soup
with go
ahead my interest uh is in mental health
and uh as as you probably all know
middle illnesses are
misunderstood and U often uh antagonist
towards those
individuals uh I'm retired now but
there's a neighbor of mine who comes
over to see me and he's very concerned
about the people that live with him are
poisoning his
food and U and uh and he finds that very
disturbing uh so he takes all of the
food puts it in his
car and uh now everybody is thinking
this man is very
strange and instead of the fact that
he's severely mentally
ill um all I can do is to say when
you're upset come and talk to me and see
if we can't uh work this
out uh he's been a homeless person uh uh
he has addictions uh he's got medical
marijuana which have got him into
trouble at work because he has the
medical marijuana in a package in his
pocket and the people at work want to
know what's in his pocket and I said
that's none of their
business uh kind of thing so that um
people don't think so much about the
issue of pain and Mental Illness but
it's been my
experience I was just telling my friend
here that I had a patient that came to
me she was very angry with me as to how
incompetent I was and she was screaming
and
hollering and she said
your confidence is about as important as
she rattled off a number
and I said can you think about that
number turned out to be her
grandfather's
birthday and it turned out that she was
sexually
molested as a child by that grandfather
she had carried that hate probably for
50 years and that's what I was
experiencing was that hate uh based on
that experience it was very um uh
enlightening uh for me uh to hear what
she had to say uh because it was clear
that what she was
carrying was was
unresolved hate towards that grandfather
that could never be
experienced so it was a unique
experience uh for me um to recognize
that the importance of that the hate
part of uh mental illness so I think
what Dave is doing is very
important if if somewhat unique in his
approach I'd love to tell you it's mine
but there's a lot of people involved in
this discussion yeah I meant your unique
approach to legislation oh
okay I actually I I wanted to know yeah
go ahead is that a right
no yes please I feel so bad we're so far
apart so good morning um representative
Nagel and members of the committee so
again my name is Heidi croll um I work
at Gallagher cahan and gartell and I
represent ahip which is America's health
insurance plan so that we're the trade
Association for um the health insurance
company so I appreciate um
representative Nagel has reached out um
a number of bills a number of occasions
so we definitely appreciate the the back
and forth dialogue and the um
opportunity to work on this um there's a
a handout here which I know I sent to um
representative Nagel and I'm happy to
send it around to others we
preped um two I think it was two years
ago when we were um there's an ad hoc
committee that was working on this issue
and so I just wanted to call your
attention to it on the first page so
it's just a one page two-sided document
but on the first page it does kind of go
over the information again it's it's
slightly dated but I think it you know
generally representative of where things
stand today as well um just kind of
about the different markets and again
just a reminder that um any legislation
that um is put into state law relative
to insurance coverage mandates um can
only apply to the fully insured um
commercial market so it's as
representative Nagel um correctly
pointed out it's it's not the
self-funded it's not Medicaid it's not
Medicare um and then within that fully
insured Market there's the individual
market and then there's the employer
sponsored Health Plan market so um and
often the state um does not apply
mandates to the individual Market
because um there could potentially be a
state Li a financial liability um
associated with that um through the ACA
so I it's just something to important to
keep in mind because I think um we need
to remember um that there are businesses
mediumsized businesses out out there
that are you know continue to struggle
to to even afford to pay for health
insurance coverage um for their
employees and so we just um want to
always keep in mind about who's going to
be paying the premiums um and you know
typically employers or perhaps employers
and employees shared so um to keep that
in mind um and the other side of this
page um and I think it's probably again
still um
representative perhaps there are some
updates but generally speaking um what
the um plan the carriers were covering
in standard plans um and again it's
important to remember there's a whole
variety of um
benefit coverage benefits that carriers
offer um to try to have a variety of
offerings and choices in the market for
employers and individuals um and so
there's you know there's a lot of
variability but um looking at sign kind
of some standard plans you can see that
chiropractic Services PT and OT 10 units
um all typically covered um acupuncture
coverage conveyor vary so there are some
plans that may cover it but not all
necessarily um gym reimbursement again
um same situation and massage um can be
covered if it's part of covered Cairo PT
or OT but not um as a standalone
typically um and then meditation again
not covered um but a number of the
carriers provide resources on their
website that's available not just to
their members but really to anybody you
can access it without a log in or
anything like that and um that provided
a couple of links here that would get
you to um kind of meditation and
mindfulness um resources that the
carriers do make available so um I just
wanted to kind of make sure it sounds
like you all have that page but I wanted
to make sure um that you had a chance to
look at it
um and I'm just looking over my notes
from when I testified on this so
um you know we one of the things that we
were concerned about um a couple of
concerns um there were 18 Services
listed and I haven't gone back to
compare and see if there are still 18
Services listed um when it was qualified
by the phrase including but not limited
to so which would indicate that there
was an unknown number of other services
you know beyond those listed um and I
think I saw the number 12 um as you know
coverage of a minimum number of visits
um for each of the services so that
would be on every single plan and so one
of the concerns we had raised during the
testimony um when this Bill had a public
hearing is that that that could put
upward pressure on the premiums and I
think that there was a fiscal note to
the bill although I didn't see it um
yeah I didn't see it either yeah so I'm
not sure where that where that landed um
the thing I saw said that unknown okay
is what I saw
um so can I just address that one thing
because that's important what you just
said so I did qualify and what I wrote
here was that you could pick 12 as a
starting point 12 visits from each
category not from every service within
that category okay okay I mean that's a
start I agree with you if this there's
innumerable Pain Care interventions I
mean you you could go on forever we do
need to put a limit right yeah yeah and
I know um representative that you
mentioned Massachusetts um the
Massachusetts law and so I don't have it
right in front of me but um from notes I
have here um in Massachusetts the
carriers um are required to ensure that
they cover at least two alternative
medication treatment options um so it's
the medication side and at least three
alternative non-medication treatment
modalities um so my understanding is
it's
non-prescriptive um so you know that um
and of course there's you know
utilization management review and
medical necessity that um overlays on
that or or underpins it um so anyway you
know the Massachusetts law is certainly
something we could look at if if that's
of interest to you um and then the other
um thing I was going to mention um and I
think it's come up in the house bill 66
um work um but it was something we
raised in our testimony as well is just
um also looking for the opportunities
around starting with education for um
providers both pcps and other types of
providers about the alternatives to
opioids um so less of a mandate but more
just focusing on some education um and
information um aspects of this as well
so um and then the final thing I'll say
which you've probably heard me say
before is that you know coverage
Services should always be um
evidence-based um they should be you
know based on clinical and scientific
ific evidence um and so you know we want
to make sure that that's part of the
conversation as well
um and I know you said you wanted to
work on this you know in the coming
weeks and months and so we're happy to
you know continue to get information to
you but I just want to kind of give you
a few touch points um while we're
kicking off the discussion today my only
goal on that was ruin in your
summer so um representative Palmer
repres so yeah my question sort of
related to this and maybe we this is
information maybe we need to get which
is um I mean with concerns about upper
pressure on premiums what's happened in
Massachusetts with their with their bill
has that been a problem or are we
substituting one modality for for pain
meds and so overall it's actually not
costing anymore and maybe it's better
for patients and so that kind of
information I mean for me that would be
very valuable and I mean I completely
agree that these that the treatments we
do include need to be evidence-based
because otherwise you you
know I can answer that if you want do
you mind I I can this be a discussion
more than like a yeah yeah you're
running the show um however
you did you want to I want to ask a
question of the insurance people
um from a provider perspective you know
forget about the premium cost forget
about the covered items forget about the
number of times that you can see a
certain
provider if in general now what I'm
trying to do is get at a very simple
concept number one we want to provide
access for patients that really need the
care for whatever reason whether the
mentally ill whether they're poor
whether they're rich whether they have
insurance or not we want to get access
to care right tell me if you agree with
these principles if the treatment is
effective meaning evidence-based so
we've proven that that the whatever
treatment we're talking about
Works provided that the the people given
the
um uh modality whatever it might be are
licensed within the state and that's
where it becomes a legislative
issue
um as far as I'm concerned would the
insurance companies cover that meaning
that would they be supportive of any
legislation that basically
says you know if it's an accepted
provider license if it is an accepted
modality if it is proven to be effective
um and as far as I'm concerned if
somebody then wants to pay cash for
whatever treatment they want whether
it's you know eating herbs in the garden
or whether it's you know whatever it
might be that's fine with me but once
you step into the insurance realm then
you have issues regarding you know lure
you know
accessibility um
and whether or not it's effective or not
is it is it your opinion that the
insurance companies would support that
sort of a concept so what I can say is I
think those are two principles that we
certainly would agree to I I don't I put
off few so what are the two that you
mentioned oh you mentioned um
evidence-based and licensed so th I'm
I'm honing in on those two things so I I
would agree with you that those are two
principles that we would agree to I
don't know what necessarily our ex
exhaustive list might be of kind of
criteria or whatever but I would agree
with you that those are two key because
you know meditation you know you you
talked about meditation being effective
or Mind Body yeah whatever Mind Body
okay so if it was proven if the massage
was proven to be effective would it be
covered by
Insurance So currently massage is
covered if it's part of like OT PT Cairo
or some other um piece let's say that
they're not PT licensed they are massage
licensed I don't it from what I
understood from the survey that we did
two years ago of the carriers that would
not be covered so um me me going me
going down to Elements Massage um so for
my very very simple you know orthop is a
very simple minded you know you got pain
you want to have a procedure or you want
to have a modality that's effective you
then want to have the people that given
it like Ed then as far as I'm concerned
the insurance can cover it okay and if
they don't I don't understand why okay
so my my question is going to be and
this not you know slam on insurance it
would be any of these you
know um massage or whatever meditation
whatever if it works I don't care you
know I we we do we do too many
procedures that are not effective you
know and I've seen that so I'm very much
aware aware of you know having you know
treatments that are effective and you
know proven to be so to be covered
that's all I would care about and that's
what I would want to know that the
insurance cover that go ahead right well
and I go ahead and then I'll say what
and and I'm thinking like one of the
problems we have is um Pain
Services are very interested in doing
procedures because they're very well
reimbursed right but not as interested
in in helping us sort out the the root
cause somebody's pain and what other
treatments might help them and um so
part of the part part of what I'm I
guess getting at is if we expand in one
way um does that reduce costs in another
way that balances out and is actually
better for the patient I think the the
the big issue that's always been
problematic for me in all these
discussions is that we apply one set of
evidence criteria for one group of
people meaning allopathic doctors and
then we apply a totally different uh
standard for non-allopathic
doctors and so you know like the bar for
like in North I I gu I remember when
they did pedicle screws and and the bar
for degenerative spine there's virtually
no evidence to support it but they they
they were able to get that with FDA
approval very easily without any really
significant evidence and you know what
I'm talking about well sure A year later
there the two years years later the
level above the fusion mass is now
sympatic right yeah so I mean that's the
problem that I had was that well when
acupuncturist you know the the
Acupuncture Project has 117 different
diagnoses with evidence and why is that
not good enough but to get to what
representative Palmer said
um this is my goal is to save everybody
money is is you know when I looked and
did the math on how many acupuncture
treatments I could do on a patient and
for the same price as one epidural
injection in in an or it was something
like 60 you know and and I was like I've
never done 60 acupuncture treatments on
anybody you know and I follow one lady
for 30 years you know and um um um I I
think that what what everybody's getting
at is we want a uniform evidence-based
criteria if there is evidence that
something works and especially I think
we're trying to save you guys money I at
the end you and the premiums and the the
people that are getting it I mean to me
that's the end game and and to answer
your question about Massachusetts I
don't think we have an answer yet but I
could ask Cindy how that worked out what
I will say is that their bill started
out looking exactly like this bill did
the bill that's in is what happened
through the legislative process okay so
yeah can I make a couple comments thank
you I'm Sabrina D I represent Anthem
Blue Cross Blue Shield um so just a
couple of off the cup thoughts in
response um to your comments so I think
we generally start from a place of
wanting something that's less invasive
and lower cost so conceptually aligned
there and I think when you start talking
about things like massage therapy they
might be licensed massage therapists but
what kind of evidence are we talking
about and if you get sort of outside the
medical evidence realm I mean I love
going to have a nice massage but if it's
not for a medical reason I mean should
that be covered by insurance I think
that's debatable um and then you get
into you can mandate you know coverage
of a service like massage therapy but
then we get into the issue of networks
we can't force providers to come into
our Network and we've run into this with
providers like acupuncturists I think
maybe
chiropractors um physical therapists and
so there's the issue of of having people
in your network because if they're not
in our Network then you know it's it's
not really
it's an issue because then they're not
contracted with us and so it's not
really helpful for our members so I just
wanted to point out sort of those
practical issues and I understand like
conceptually I think we're probably
aligned but I think when you start to
peel back the layers it's a little more
complicated than just saying okay if it
works we should cover it so do you mind
so you mind I ask a question you know I
would I would argue that invasive does
not necessarily mean it is you want to
go to the the least invasive first so if
you have a a fractured femur you know
doing massage therapy is not going to
work period right we know that unless
you're a baby and you know stuff like
that we don't fix him but you know so
less invasive you know may be the best
way to go and the most coste effective
down the road because you're done with
the you've done you're dealt with the
problem and you're done with it um but
having said that you know what I'm
saying is that you know I I would push
back a little bit on the premise that if
it's less invasive we want to start
there first I would I would argue
against that um and that's not from a
surgical point of view that's just from
what is the best way to treat that
patient at that point in time and who's
the best person to do it so to me really
it comes down to it's you know what is
the diagnosis what is the proven
effective therapies who is licensed to
provide that therapy and as far as I'm
concerned it should be a covered product
now whether or not they're in your
network or not that's up to the provider
to decide if they choose not to do it
and they want to take cash because
they're good at what they do and there's
a lot of people that in hospitals in New
York City that will take cash in fact
that's the only way the way they will do
the practices to take cash and why
because it's a status symbol it's a
status symbol to say you know I will
do you know this procedure but I'll only
take cash because I don't want to deal
with the enems the signas the Blue Cross
Blue Shields of the world so um again
you know you know you're coming up from
an insurance perspective I'm coming at
it from a patient care perspective and
to me it's a little bit different well
we are also coming at it from a what's
best for our members perspective and I
just on this issue of Licensing we we
can't functionally just base bringing
providers or or they're not even really
providers just people who provide a
service into Network simply because
they're licensed I mean that would be a
massive array of professions that are
licensed so we really I mean we're
health insurance so it has to be medical
and I think I think the jury's still out
on massage therapy I mean I think I I'm
not aware of of like medical evidence um
that it sort of treats or helps certain
illnesses or what you know diagnoses and
maybe maybe that is out there but I
think we we cannot just have it hinge on
licensing
alone can I ask that a question to that
so we apply both of those things
evidence-based plus license does that
make a difference
I think so yeah I mean we have to have
the medical evidence and and it's been a
while since I've talked to Dr laflor our
medical our chief medical director um
and again a lot of this is like I'm
digging deep because it's been a few
months since we've talked about these
issues but yeah I mean I think those
things go hand in hand sorry I yeah and
like I like I said I I think that those
are two key aspects but I don't know
that it's the exhaustive list so yeah
yeah so my primary goal is to patients
have access to the right Care at the
right time by the right person period so
to me you make you you apply the kiss
principle to the bill the legislature
that is put forward you make it as
simple as possible and if what we're
talking about is having you know for
mental health issues for True pain for
whatever the issue is you have the right
therapy that is proven to be effective
given by the person that is the best to
give that then it for my line thinking
that is the the the end goal of the bill
um from what I can see from what I look
at and if somebody wants to pay cash
knock yourself out but you know they may
not be included you know within your
network
because the the modality is not
considered
a um proven effective treatment but they
wanted to do it anyway so they pay cash
let them pay cash um good job um that's
perfect that's exactly what I what you
were getting at before was the idea that
if you say couldn't find chiropractors
to join your networker because they're
too happy just taking the cash would
would the insurance company be penalized
and so there has to be some work end for
that um I totally agree I I I'll be
honest when I went through this bill
last night and I rewrote it and I
re-edited and things like that that was
one thing that jumped out at me was that
whole issue of you have to have this
many providers for each of these
Services I I I didn't like that and that
needs to be changed but that that's what
was in the bill um I had a question that
I don't really understand that maybe all
of you can help me with so you talked
about the whole mandate issue and things
like that what I struggle to understand
is when when we started with this bill
we just started with a concept and when
it ended up actually in writing all of a
sudden there was a separate sections for
group and indiv idual insurance but we
never talk about like the orisa type
groups the self-insure groups things
like that I know we can't talk about the
federal insured I don't know why we
can't talk about
mcos um um maybe you can clarify for
that but why are they not included in
that discussion because we're basically
throwing out
about probably about 30 to 40% of the
market for reasons I don't
understand so
the simply the way are the regulatory
structure works um at the state level
what the New Hampshire insurance
department has the authority to regulate
is the fully insured plans both in the
individual market and in the the
employer Market the group Market um so
the self-funded plans for example are
regulated at the federal level um
Medicaid is a completely separate set of
statutes obviously having federal and
state um um partnership there um
Medicare Federal um so you know one of
the other things that that we had talked
about is the the work that's going on in
the house bill 66 um um committee your
study committee or working group um
and you know I think from our perspect
and there's a discussion there around
doing some pilot um some pilot work
perhaps either with the Medicaid Program
or perhaps the state Employee Program or
um and
so I think there is a lot of overlap
with what's in here as well so
um that's just the lay of the land that
we have in terms of what we can actually
impact with our state laws so we like
can I mean do we I mean I don't know
what percentage of the market for
example in MCO like the Medicaid
expansion has can we have any say on
that
too not through these statutes you would
have have to do it through the Medicaid
statues in in the New Hampshire so
there's yeah and I I'm not a Medicaid um
for the life that's not my area of
expertise so uh that's something you'd
have to talk with um somebody from HHS
about in terms of yeah you know what
coverage they could do and then how what
sort of permission if any is required at
the federal level and that sort of thing
so and for the late me I didn't really
understand why we don't talk about
them same issues what was your initial
concept you mentioned initial concept so
I mean we just I mean we basically took
this the original bill that Cindy had
created for Massachusetts that's where
all this started I mean where we started
was to actually look at representative L
grin's it wasn't I guess it was his bill
at that time no it wasn't it was map's
bill at that time and we we looked at
that and then we modified it and came up
with what's the second sections of this
bill what was the primary goal concept
that you talked about I mean pretty much
everything you just said I mean we we
wanted to provide access to these
services and what we were representing
was actually not providers but we were
representing patients right so it
started with the US pain Foundation
Massachusetts pain initiative the New
Hampshire pain collaborative which I was
one of the founders of so the bill
actually came from those groups of
people with input from the medical
society so Physicians got involved and
then once that was done then we kind of
reached out to other groups and that how
chiropractors got involved acupuncturist
got involved um we've never really had
involvement with massage people psych
very peripherally um um but the bill is
being written from a patient perspective
and that's kind of why I feel
that that this is an important
discussion to continue because we're
representing the patients not the
providers does that
help it does did you ever read the book
The said it out
did you ever read the book called The
Citadel by Cronin written in
1939 there's one line in there at the
very end that talks about the fact that
as soon as money got involved in health
care it destroyed the
system 1939 figure yeah well this is you
know this happened in 1939 so I mean it
was present you know for many reasons
but uh we faced that with rvus you know
in the 1990s and and you knew that when
that happened this was going to be the
downfall of medicine in general but
having said that the the concept here
what we're fighting over whether it's
Insurance language or it we're going to
be looking at it if if I have if I have
any part of this it will be from the
patient perspective you know um and not
not the dollars and cents perspective so
what I'm saying is that the Citadel was
present back in 39 and what I'm saying
is that my primary goal as I think is
with chairman Nagel is the patient
perspective you know how this care is
delivered Ju Ju Just so I can say um
having read The Sermon on the Mount this
week it that actually that statement
actually came from The Sermon on the
Mount um you can either worship God or
money you don't have a choice Love or
Money basically so it's been around for
and he was quoting other people so
that's a 3,000 year old concept so can I
just read the book resp I just want to
say we agree and want we want what is
best for our members always we want them
to be healthy we want them to have
access to whatever Healthcare is
appropriate we also balance that with um
you know there's a reason we have
networks there's a reason we have a
credentialing process um and so part of
it is making sure that the provide the
people providing the care are providing
quality appropriate care and have all
the correct licensing and education
background Etc so um I think we come
from the same place of wanting what's
best for patients in our case it's our
members so I never asked this question
before of the insurance companies but I
it made me think of when you said that
you mentioned credentialing do you do
privileging as well and the difference
is that with credentialing for a
hospital say is that you check the boxes
off you went to a med school you did
this you did The Residency Etc the
privileging is what allows you to do in
various hospitals the various procedures
that you do so I'm an orthopedist and I
was trained to do spine but I should not
be privileged to do spine okay so my my
question for the insurance care is do
you privilege you know providers in your
network or are you just
credentialing I would have double check
I I'm fairly certain the privileging is
on the provider like Hospital side yeah
but the insurance companies don't look
at that and say this providers should
not be doing this sort of management of
propan
um I mean I think we we try to track
certain coding issues and sometimes can
find people are doing maybe practicing
outside the scope of what they should be
that sort of stuff that gets into a
realm that is outside my general
wheelhouse but um but yeah I think
generally privileging is outside our our
realm okay thank
you I oh go ahead I want to go back try
to keep minutes here this is challenging
go ahead
I uh it's very important to me that
middle illness get to be part of this
and and that's for different reasons
than what we've
heard uh everybody knows that uh stigma
is a major issue in other words in the
legislature there are going to be people
who don't want to hear about mental
illness because their perception
is the public
perception that it's
stigmatized and if you support mental
illnesses there probably something to
matter with you uh and also there there
is
insurance coverage or mental illness
that's a very broad
spectrum uh from Neurosis to
psychosis and some are highly treatable
and some are
extremely difficult to uh treat uh and
if you talk to the average person they
don't think of it as an illness they
think of it as a problem uh so that from
my point of view anything that I can
associate mental illness with that
clearly defines it as an illness and
treatable uh and frankly I go back to
the days when the old New Hampshire
hospital was there and there are still
people who believe in that that old
hospital you've never left there uh I've
had friends that were spent their whole
life at New Hampshire hospital because
nobody knew what to do I was never
critical of that but until thorine came
there was really no
treatment and so I think what I'm
talking about is is a different type of
problem in terms of in inclusion in the
pain
concept but in in a strange way mental
illness causes pain for other people as
much as it causes pain in
individuals and therefore a very
different problem in terms of of
insurance coverage and and who is uh
available uh so I keep pushing this and
I have for years um and I think this is
an unusual opportunity for people to
begin to look at mental illness in a
different way and that example of how
somebody was carrying pain for years
untreated uh because her behavior
probably was provocative and uh making
her it's a different kind of reaction to
pain that reaction is to be provocative
and irritate people instead of the the
average pain I've had some recent pain
and frankly I don't get much Sy
from the doctor that sits next to
me he's been I have to be honest he was
very helpful to me at a difficult time
he saw that I could aride home every
single so lot nicer than representative
M representative mck I can say that you
know the carriers do provide certainly a
a wide um and deep array of you know
mental health behavioral health um
services so and I think that that that
that was reflected a little bit in the
definition of pain that came up in the
house bill 66 and I apologize I have to
run to an 11 o'clock meeting so I'm
sorry that's okay I just wanted you to
know why I was running off I'm really
glad you came thanks may I just ask that
in this chart that you provided if you
updated could you include Mental Health
Services just so we know I mean I I I'm
just they're probably covered
but yeah that would be
a okay yeah
but in general were you asking about I
mean mental health services there is a
vast array that have covered I I
guess maybe looking at if there are ones
that are included in this current bill
that are not currently covered just I we
know okay I mean
and maybe that's a lot to ask but are
are we asking for more in this bill than
you already we think that CBT is like
really important for managing chronic
pain so that's a big issue so um
representative
Dolan I feel guilty we should all just
be at a small table I know we could we
could reorient the room we probably get
in trouble though right I did do that
once yeah they can come and sit down oh
yeah you're right good
thinking thank you Mr chairman um just
three quick point my name is uh
representative Tom Dolan
I'm actually on the Edna committee so
some of the questions you have probably
you might want to think about bringing
in OPC to talk about some of the
licensing and so forth um but I had
three quick points I wanted to make I'm
a co-sponsor I'm here representing
primarily the sponsor representative
lungren uh he's a chiro practicing
chiropractor and uh in his uh clinical
experience
he sees a lot of people that come to him
that are using
opioids for their pain management and
they come to him with the question is
can you help me get off of these opioids
I don't want to take them anymore but
I'm afraid to stop or I the pain is such
that I can't stop so that's that's one
of the issues I know representative nle
talked about uh the fact you've got this
for this summer I would encourage you
not to let this go to continue to work
it there's there's such a treasure of
opportunity here to help New Hampshire
Society but that's one the chiropractors
are seeing in the in their practices of
of how to transition those who are are
in pain to something that is maybe
massage has a massage solution maybe it
doesn't but um but the representative
mentioned that it really depends on the
on the particular case the the second uh
issue was referred to me by a classmate
of mine who uh is a practicing
anesthesiologist
and uh he's now transitioned uh into
pain
management and what he tells me is that
uh those
folks uh after they have a surgery for
example they often transition to an
opioid solution or opioid like solution
and then the next step is to transition
off off that medicine and that's and
that's the difficult part is to how to
get off the medicine and what do you use
what what assistance is available to
them maybe mental health assistance uh
maybe uh medicinal assistance to get off
of that medicine and trans transition to
to a less medicated world for
and thirdly I want to mention uh an
experience that I've had I'm I'm a six
six term town counseler in
londondary and a lot of experience with
our first respond responders especially
in the fire
department uh dealing with the opioid
crisis that we've all been dealing with
for the last 20 25 years uh it is such a
uh a crippling force in our our society
that it's again something not to let go
of that that if we got this tiger by the
tail let's keep wrestling it to see if
we can come up with some good Solutions
there's one issue that that's beyond the
scope of what you're talking about today
but I'm I'm happy to come back at
another time I brought this to HHS uh a
couple of years ago and and that is U
what I'll call uh medicine cabinet
diving um and that is uh those of us
mostly parents who have experienced some
pain and some pain management and have
not finished out their prescription all
the doctors say finish a prescription
and be done with it they ends up leaving
half a dozen pills in the medicon
cabinet and then at house party or
whatever somebody discovers that and
decides to uh take advantage of of that
situation and there there is a I propose
solution to that believe it or not uh it
was not well received by the Chief of
Police Association oh so but again I'd
be happy to talk to you about that some
other time but uh yeah we should I I
really appreciate what you just said
this has been a 35y year process for me
trying to find that sweet spot because
opioids are important we use them at end
of life we use them for cir we use them
in selected patient with chronic pain
and and and they have value for the
right person and we've been saying that
for 35 years and we actually created our
first set of opioid prescribing I'm dick
I'm being pro whatever we created our
first set of opioid prescribing rules we
wrote them in 1998 for the state and I
still to this day believe that if we had
taken those seriously that we could have
prevented a lot of the problems that did
happen because I'll tell you the media
took off I have a beautiful headline
from us world news and business report
about how morphine is a cure for
everything I mean that that was in the
media and I like I love how we like to
blame big Pharma for everything but you
know there's a lot of people to blame
but we really tried hard to hit the
sweet spot and I think that is to me why
this I'm I really appreciate what you
just said because that's why what we're
doing here to me is important um and I
appreciate what David said about what
you said for him that was wonderful I
would encourage you to not not to let
this go to to keep studying it and and
and find some solutions because it we so
badly need it in our
so I'm I'm here if you have any
questions but I'm I'm not an expert and
I'm not a practitioner or a
clinician I'm trying to think do I have
questions for you because I do Dr Dr
representative lunger and I have talked
a lot about this for several years and I
really appre sad that he's not here but
I think when we meet next time he can be
he's on vacation so figures he's got the
best Tan in the state house for a reason
I'm wondering a little bit about the
silos of medical care where if you know
if
the if it costs more for the insurance
company to provide expanded services but
they're savings somewhere else the
insurance company doesn't see it the
rates go up and so to what degree that's
going to be a confounding thing because
you know if somebody if you know if
towns or ER end up with a lot of people
Landing there now presumably if they
have with overdoses say if presumably if
they have insurance that's going to get
covered but it's also but it's going to
be covered by insurance so if we can
prevent that that should save the
insurance company's money but on the
other hand there are a lot of expenses
that go with opiate overuse that are not
covered by anything other than you know
people trying to piece together things
like Sullivan County has a whole medical
assisted treatment plan that's covered
not through Insurance because these
people don't have it yeah and if we
could lower that cost because we just
you know have a big increase in county
in the county tax rate and some of it's
that kind of expense that that maybe
would be
reduced and how do you sort of those of
us on on the front
lines the moms and dads in the homes on
the front lines what they run into is
scary and it's usually in the laundry
room as they're emptying the pockets
before they put the jeans in the in the
washing machine with what's this what
are what are these pills I just found
and and what do I do with them where do
I bring them do I flush them down the
toilet no that's not good for the
environment do I throw them out the car
window next time I go to the store
no uh so what do I do with them so that
that's I'll leave you with that little
tidbit of of on the on the plus side
when I had shoulder surgery two years
ago um I got sent home with um an ice
you know an ice pack thing and four
oxycodones and um that's I need I took
two the first night at the you know the
surgeon said you better take these the
first night and then after that I never
needed anything now that's partly luck
that I didn't end up having a lot of
pain but also partly what's changed when
I had neck surgery 10 years ago I got
sent home with 60 oxycodon right so I
think there's a lot of a lot of the
practice that's going the right
direction but we still have ation that
that's in here is is very important I I
like you I had some surgery I had a a
hernia surgery and I was being
discharged the nurse brought me
prescription for 30 oxycodon and I said
I don't want them I said give me five
right and and and we'll keep the other
25 in the pharmacy I don't I don't want
that many because then I got to dispose
of them yeah and I didn't want to I'm
going to give a plug here for Dartmouth
right because Dr bar and others um we
don't agree much on chronic pain but on
acute pain we do but they published a
study on on prescribing opioids after
routine surgeries and came to the
conclusion that everybody's throwing
pills out well and that they need to
prescribe differently yeah because those
that are here that have some gray here
remember the
fifth yeah Vital sign Vital sign that we
used to have to live by in the 90s that
pain and so we were forced in large part
not by farmer not by anybody else except
by our own societies to give away you
know opioids a very excessive rate um so
we did have the fifth Bal sign it's
taking us a while to get over that
hangover I remember the number of
patients who would say I have a right to
right you know yeah yeah if you look at
my description you have a right but you
also responsibility because people I
actually just wanted to tie in
everything that all you guys are saying
because I think it's really important
legislatively
um I it's why I wanted to differentiate
between what we're talking about in our
integrative care committee and what
we're talking about here um what you
were saying Bill if I can call you bill
um is when we when we created that that
integrative care committee we we we
acknowledg that in chronic pain that
multimodality therapy is important that
it be coordinated and integrative and it
needs to be done in a coste effective
manner that nobody's figured out how to
do yet
and so that's the whole point of that
committee is to figure out strategies to
do that using Community existing
community services and uh you know and
that's been exciting and there's a lot
of people that are really interested in
that that the difference between that
and this bill is we're looking at Uni
modality therapies for really more you
know some of this is for chronic pain
but a lot of it's for acute pain you
know you know you're not going to go to
50 different providers hopefully for a
sprained ankle but you know you might
find that you want access to a
chiropractor for an acute back pain or
whatever and there's clear evidence to
support that and so how do we and I
think it's really important that we
differentiate that these are two
different bills even though there's a
lot of overlap and that we do need to
give access to integrative care here but
also you need modality or B modality
care easily cost effectively and do the
right thing and I I really you said it
three times I think that how important
what we're doing here is and I really
appreciate that because this is a really
big deal to me thank you for what you're
doing can I ask you a question sure you
know in in in reality um I remember when
we looked at this bill uh 554 back in
23 and I wrote down some comments I made
here one of them was I agree with the
intent but it should not be
legislated and there's a lot of us that
are in practice that know of the
alternatives for uh non opio good
management of pain but do we use them
regularly no we don't should we perhaps
uh but the question I have and again as
a co-sponsor of the bill is I wrote down
should not be legislated what should be
legislated I guess that's what we're
trying to get at also is what should be
legislated and what should not be
legislated um and I think those are you
don't have to answer that now but if you
can send to our chairman you know
because I think we're going to have to
work on this a little bit longer I I I
would relish that opportunity yeah but
it's a great question uh
probably a group of of experts like
yourselves that uh I mean that that are
clinician that have clinical experience
probably have much better uh group of
suggestions than I would have but uh
again uh talking with h representative
lungren he's just looking for
alternative to opio and what what are
the Alternatives and uh can what can we
do to provide those alternatives to our
to our patients so my question to us as
well as you and to representative
lungren is what should we do
legislatively because I'm always
hesitant quite honestly to legislate
medicine in the care that we provide
because I think that we do it well
majority of the time but having said
that we were given that fifth Vital sign
20 something years ago and we're still
getting over that hangover but I
couldn't agree more you know my goal is
patient Centric it's access to whatever
modality works best it is to basically
know that it's effective that the
provider is good at giving that modality
and then to have them not suffer
financially from doing that so how we do
that legislatively I don't really know
the answer to that but that's why I
would reach out to you and to
representative lungren and others to say
you know what can we do to streamline
this process and I think I can speak for
the chiropractors because I met um with
both the Chiropractic associations their
leadership to talk about this and I I
think there's two driving forces for
this particular Bill one is is the is
the chiropractors more so than any other
alternative provider and then the other
is the patients you know as we were
talking about before but
um when I first arrived in New Hampshire
you know people would go to see a
chiropractor and go see them two to
three times a week forever and insurance
is paid for that and now um they're
struggling to get any coverage you know
in a lot of situations and so you know
they went from famine or Feast to famine
and so they want to bring it back to
some seat at the table and they're
really the ones that are the driving
force I'll be honest I haven't had a
huge a lot of you know acupuncturists
you know they're very interested in this
but they're not the driving force
um but I think from a legislative
standpoint is they feel like they've
been left out and they feel that this is
the way they need to do things to get
back left
in and and whether we need to do that or
not that's another story but that's
that's their feel I know that's their
feeling that's what they vocalized to me
and I as a doctor who treats pain I
valued what they offer for a very long
time
so it's it's in in terms of
management um some whoever becom
speaker uh
technically decides what committee
that's going to it should
automatically go to help but you never
know but there's a FN after the HB on
top that means a fiscal note so I looked
up the fiscal note and they don't have
one yeah but that that doesn't mean
there won't be
one and therefore that means it will go
to finance um
committee so that uh we want to keep in
mind that what committee gets this bill
is very
significant and what we sometimes think
is simple you know that it just should
automatically go to help doesn't
necessarily happen if I could say this
is a bill that exists and it's in our
committee okay yep stay there yes and
that's why we're dealing with it do you
know what what the issue was with the
fiscal note no yes when they first put
this up fiscal impact due to time
constraints lbo the um office of
legislative budget assistance could not
provide a physical not but they didn't
say that there should be one or should
not be they just said because of time
constraints and this is back with the
original bu right and so my question
about that is being is um isn't the
fiscal note what it's going to cost the
state not that the state shouldn't care
whether patients or insurance companies
pay more but shouldn't it I mean if it's
if it's not going to cost the Health
Human Services or whatever other part of
the state more then it shouldn't have a
this is what not confuses me because in
one of my other bills there was a fiscal
note there was like zero cost to the
state yeah yeah and then they put an
fiscal note on and then they were trying
to estimate the cost to other entities
that weren't right and and I mean I I
don't want to have it understand cost a
lot more either because I same county
budget the um health insurance cost is
up 16% so we don't want to keep don't
want to keep pushing cost there too and
that's why I'm really interested in
whether aside from better patient care
if we can that that doing this right
might lead to actual lower costs just so
you know I've done 64,000 epidurals in
my
career if I never do another one I'm
fine and would I ever let anybody do it
to me probably not so I mean and that's
an expensive intervention and I I just
think that's what we're trying to do is
save the system money by providing
access to stuff that doesn't cost as
much and the other thing that's really
important for pain management is
self-management and when you time
somebody into me to do an injection
that's they can't do that on their own
at home I don't think so um you know we
want to give them as many tools as they
can use that are cost effective so they
don't need to run to the doctor every
time they have a problem they can manage
it themselves and that saves everybody
money I think we should check I'll be
glad to go to the LBA and see if they do
have a fiscal note because that if if it
costs outside people right those become
opponents of the legisl right yeah right
I I can see a certain representative on
the finance committee not liking
this they might actually like well
certain people might actually like it
after I saw at the last
session um can I just move this to the
next step so um we should probably start
talking about our summer study um like
I'm like I'm just thinking who should be
invited um to a discussion and like the
four of us are here we don't need more
than four I mean it's uh where is mar is
he on vacation no he um he's he had a
conflict he's a great member he and he
wanted to be here but he couldn't and um
chairman McDonald wanted to be here also
this was a really big thing for him um
but he's out of town so um so there's
six of us um and then I mean who else
should be there and I I mean I um and I
can name people off the top of my head
but you guys go ahead well it seem to me
like the stakeholders should be there
yeah so the chiropractors somebody that
represents chiropractor somebody that
represent the insurance company somebody
that represents the um acupuncturist you
know what what is their you know you
know opinion regarding this bill so I
already have um names for all those
spots so um and we should let the
insurers come back um and um want to
meet again what's that when would want
to meet again um
you know it's kind of funny because
we've actually achieved something here I
think so you don't want to put it off
too long right well and the other right
I was going to say the other thing is
said I will completely have forgotten
what we talked about today if it goes to
I'm gonna I have like 47 Pages a minut
be um I was thinking like mid July is
that too far away no I'm gone until the
12th to 13th so all right after that
after the 13th so I'm sorry you're hurt
my so we're talking about pain for me to
look at you hurts my neck so that's why
I been been looking at you that
much um I will grab my book and we this
could be this is the other thing
um we wanted to be Zoom or do we want it
to be in person because if it's an ad
hoc meeting we can do what we want I
think it's much better in person but it
would be it have people have the option
thanks for coming yeah thanks that was
really helpful
I'd say in person you know but if people
get stuck and they have to do Zoom they
can do Zoom but it's much having
attended meetings by Zoom it's so much
better in person you don't feel yeah and
we we actually have a hybrid thing that
we're doing for our thing tomorrow at
the we're doing it at the hire Hospital
Association I don't know if we can use
state property for can we use state
property for a meeting for an ad hoc
meeting I can check oh sure yeah so if
we can like if we can meet here on an ad
hoc basis it's just to get it in the
calendar all right but if it's ad hoc we
don't need it in the calendar as long as
they fix the air condition that is all
going to be up to when um our daughter
has the baby in which case I might be in
New York so then a zoom would be handy
okay yeah it's an option do you want to
do
like Wednesday July 7 that doesn't work
for you 17th let me open like yeah that
I think I'm working
yeah yeah I'm I'm working you're gonna
get so sick of me this
summer I'm working that day unless you
want to have it at like 6:00 am in which
case no no I'm sorry I'm a POS iatrist
we don't start that early so I'm I'm
either free the the week
before pretty much you're not before the
week how about the week after the 24th
sure if we have two meetings that should
be good enough I think so yeah and then
we'll meet as a committee committee in
September right this is fun you go
legislation and action oh
boy yeah does that work you know what
time um same time 10 works good for
me we made a decision today actually
made a lot of decisions so what I'll do
decision about when to meet well we we
kind of decided like what not to do
today what the goals are too I mean that
was important goals so um I'll I'll I'll
put together all the minutes okay um and
I'll try to do as good as I can um and
then I'll I'll share them with you guys
that's all right with you I really I I
don't know what the requirements are for
posting
them I
don't
yeah yeah and then um um just the Comm
system right we could keep forgetting
about her she she takes care of all
those she's really wonderful so I'll
just give her my notes and tell her to
type it up no that's never happening
well this was fun all right so we'll do
it then and then um I mean can I just
ask like one brief snapshot question
like um what and you don't have to
answer it if you don't want but just how
I ended the bill
and if you don't want to answer don't
worry about it yeah if you haven't
looked at it don't worry about it yeah
say I I I read through it but it's it's
going to be a lot more productive to go
back and look at it again now that I
feel really guilty about what I did but
um when we saw the original Bild the pre
version um it it just it had a huge
number of problems only in that
everything that was already in
except that they were going to make you
write up every time you wrote you had to
write up a plan that you had to submit
to somebody you know about what you were
doing that didn't involve opioids we
already have to do that it's St it's
isn't statute it's in the medical rules
so there was nothing in there that we
didn't have to do already um and they
didn't really they put in a lot of
modalities that we know were not going
to be able to cover so um we had to get
rid of a lot of that then we start
strugg when we we discussed the license
thing which was not in the original Bill
the first section um that was really
important to us that it be a licensed
provider that evidence-based that was
not in the original bill that that was
important yeah right oh good thing so
yeah because the other thing would be
like if
it it it can't increase administrative
burden because otherwise I mean you
don't want somebody to go like well I
could go through this jump through these
hoops or I could write for some oxyon
yeah and although there are Hoops for
that too but yeah well it was it was
crazy I just took one look at it and I
just saw nobody's going to want to do
pain management if you do this and that
that was the barrier because people
already don't want to do management we
want to make it easier and I understand
what he was trying to do and what they
were trying to do but it just it didn't
make it wasn't going to work and that's
why we sat down as a group to try to
figure out well how can we this has
value how do we make it workable for a
doctor to do is there anything in that
build that costs
money to to the St I person you know the
cost of the paper of printing it I I
don't I think it's to the system really
but with the original bill yeah because
um and that that may be why the fiscal
notes a challenge is because in the
original Bill there was a form a doctor
would have to fill out that would have
to be submitted to to somebody and that
somebody would have to keep track of
that so that would may be where the
fiscal vote came
from so you can't retire no
no well I think it's probably you have
to write in all right
okay we'll just have this Mass Lebanon
campaign you're in Handover
right I didn't I was so happy when you
said you were coming because I thought
when I knew you weren't running I
thought you'd be like a lame duck and
you wouldn't because I I was psyched
when you said you'd
come actually I was psyched when you
said you'd come too yeah pH was a given
I decided at the last second
that
say is he retired from you
too oh because I knew he retired from
practice he
is yeah
done can we make a motion to
adjourn all in favor I boom here there
that was fun that's
not I know I was going to bring I have a
Stanley hammer in my car truck I was
going to bring it in and do that but I
didn't want to Dent the
table when you get to be a a real
chairman they'll give you a gther oh
really oh yeah yeah yeah I remember you
took a picture I don't even remember
what that was of or what that was about
I remember you making me I I got a kick
out of
the e